pour ce médecin de toulouse l'entente
france québec est inopérante
du côté québécois sais rien parce que
notre diplôme est reconnu mais on peut
pas travailler
commençons par régler le cas du docteur
caruhel le ministre de la santé n'a pas
apprécié les critiques de ses collègues
français qui dénonce n'ont pas
l'obligation de faire un stage
d'adaptation mais latente pour ce stage
qui dépassent souvent deux ans et il
voudrait choisissant son endroit de
stage c'est pas demain que ça marche
au québec c'est du plus claire dolan le
médecin français écoutent la réaction du
ministre et corrige le tir
alors je pense qu'il a eu des données
erronées ou il a mal compris le
reportage j'y ai cru elle a exprimé sa
préférence pour montréal menachem ait
refusé de faire un stage ailleurs vous
seriez prêt à aller à l'extérieur
demande forcément parce que j'attends ce
stage mois donc quel que soit l'endroit
où se situera le stage ce stage de trois
mois est à faire donc je le ferai bien
entendu n'importe où au québec en france
où jusque l'esprit de l'entente n'est
pas respectée car les compétences des
médecins français sont mises en doute
là ils sont vraiment traités comme des
élèves où ils n'ont pas le droit de
faire grand chose alors qu'ils
pourraient être très utiles tout de
suite oui peut-être qu'il ya un certain
problème dans certains délais dans
certains camps mais l'entente elle est
respectée tel qu'il a été signé
n'en déplaise à nos vis-à-vis france il
ya beaucoup de réserves qui sont
exprimés ce n'est pas du tout l'avis du
commissaire aux plaintes de l'office des
professions qui a fait une vérification
particulière sur l'entente france québec
à la suite d'une plainte des autorités
françaises vous recommander que cette
entente loi soit revue de façon assez
important que je dirais complètement
parce que dans ses fondements on n'a pas
les fondements de ce qui est exigé dans
l'entente signée entre le 1er mai
charest et le président sarkozy tout le
commissaire les différences de nos
systèmes de santé ne justifie pas
l'imposition d'un stage de trois mois et
une supervision de cinq ans surtout si
la tente pour les stages est longue
ils estiment que le collège des médecins
a sa part de responsabilité une
condition qui est injustifiée ou une
mesure de compensation qui est pas
réalisable
ça donnerait un obstacle il y a un an le
commissaire avait recommandé au collège
des médecins de renégocier l'entente de
fond en comble
ce fut aujourd'hui et mathieu barrette
était en mode de dison offensif mais ce
qu'il a des réponses aux critiques des
médecins français savez on dit souvent
que l'attaqué la meilleure des défenses
donc oui le docteur barrette a critiqué
la crédibilité du docteur caruhel
notamment en affirmant que le médecin
attendrait son stage non pas depuis 10
mois comme on le disait hier dans le
reportage mais depuis sept huit mois
donc il attire l'attention sur des
détails comme ça ce qui lui permet
d'éviter de répondre aux griefs des
médecins français qui sont bien réels il
veut que cette entente là soit modifié
ils ont vraiment l'impression que le
stage qui est imposé ils ne sont pas
contraints mais le fait qu'il l'ait
presque irréalisable ses attentes la
font en sorte que les médecins ils se
découragent de rester au québec d'où de
déménager au québec est un réel blocage
et ils veulent que ça soit réglé le
sujet des autres médecins étrangers vous
nous parler des syriens récemment limite
saint cyrien alors est ce que il ya des
solutions est ce que les choses bougent
dans ce dossier là mais la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et les david a
rencontré les doyens des facultés de
médecine et les recteurs des universités
judy dernier mais ce que le ministre
barrette ne disait aujourd'hui c'est que
lui et elles vont les rencontrer à
nouveau dans les prochains jours ou plus
tard dans deux semaines pour vraiment
tenté d'obtenir des réponses et des
débuts de solution à ce blocage pour
améliorer l'accès à la formation aux
stages aux résidences pour les médecins
étrangers
très bien merci beaucoup sa fille vous
entrez